competitive integrity is an important
part of esports
if someone is cheating they don't just
invalidate their own achievements
but those of their teammates as well and
even respected pro players on top teams
have risked it all by turning to hacks
to improve their performance
but it would be nearly impossible to
follow through on cheating allegations
without some sort of detection system
and valve anti-cheat
or vac is exactly that yeah if you
clicked on this video looking for an
explanation of veteran affairs canada
i'm sorry but this ain't it chief
anyway you're probably wondering why
people spam
back in the chat during esports streams
well
the vax system was first introduced to
counter-strike in 2002
and was designed to replace punk buster
another common anti-cheat system
for all valve games unlike the manual
reporting systems found in most games
vac and automated systems like it detect
the presence of foreign code
manipulations
used by players to gain a competitive
advantage
and if detected vac responds with
disciplinary action
when it first launched vac would issue
suspensions for
varying lengths of time when cheats were
detected
but by 2005 bans were permanent
from that point on vac banned players
were unable to compete on vac secured
servers
which meant that cheaters who wanted to
keep playing probably ended up against
other cheaters on unsecured servers and
again
the bans are permanent and
non-negotiable
[__] off means [__] off this permanent
status has caused
many to beg for forgiveness leading to
some
hilarious results something stupid
happened
i'm not allowed to have my own cell
phone so my dad forced me to use his
phone number
my dad has a steam too and uses the same
number today
my brother used my dad's account and
cheated and now my main account is vac
banned
it's true and here is a proof my father
will now write too
hello i'm the father and what my son
says is true
he did not cheat it was his brother on
my account
please unban him valve sincerely the
father
please unban to put it into perspective
here are some things that are more
likely to happen than your vac ban being
lifted
being born with 11 fingers or toes
dating a millionaire being a us high
school baseball player
who makes it to the pros or launching a
successful startup
over time vac has continued to develop
other supporting resources
including vac net which uses deep
learning to help valve
stay ahead of cheaters but while vac had
been around for over a decade
it was in 2014 that cheating and
counter-strike
began to get really out of hand
especially with regards to account
boosting
valve worked to correct a lot of the
problems including reverting
rank gains and losses from games that
involved
recently banned cheaters but by the end
of the year
what would become known as the vacuning
was in full effect
and as cs go esports continued to grow
the vac hammer began to drop in more
dramatic fashion
get him into these situations very
quickly with his awp and just kind of
let him go to work
they don't even have a man backing him
right now you know that buddy says he
does not exist it's just simple on his
own lone wolf
with the awp he's out in russia william
is just sniping
did emilio just get back banned
[Music]
what what
what what did we just see i yeah i think
this is a first like an official match
and it's not like you know i looked over
and i was like oh he just got
disconnected or whatever maybe he's just
rebooting and then you see like vac
you're
oh i was like
following emilio's ban other pros
including
sf smn and perhaps most notably
titans callie were banned as well and by
the way
everyone in the french scene including
the player in question
pronounces it cali it's not cookley or
cuckly or whatever the hell i keep
reading from people in our video comment
sections
don't add me just don't wow what do you
say after that one brutal
savage wrecked all of the aforementioned
players
admitted that they had cheated and some
even tried to point fingers at
other players they believed were
cheating too
the vacuning was in full swing and it
seemed clear that valve's efforts in
would ensnare even more pros in a game
of insane flick shots
mind-blowing wall bangs
are you kidding and millisecond fast
reactions
in a good position oh what anyone could
be a cheater
and so a hysteria took over an armchair
vac enthusiast
everywhere linked clips of pros that
they believed
were suspicious common targets during
the witch hunt were fanatics flusha
crims jw and olofmeister
partially because of the team's rise and
subsequent dominance
pro players were commenting on it like
shocks was saying on stream yeah
these are obviously cheats you know i've
seen cheats before you know like
people it wasn't just fans it wasn't
just hltv or p they were actual pro
players i mean i won't mention the other
names but i know other players for top
teams
who either were like yeah they
definitely cheat or were like oh [__]
those guys they probably do cheat
none of them were ever banned nor has
their cheating been proven
and they would go on to become one of
the most decorated cs go rosters
of all time and by the end of 2014
the vac craze had even spread to twitch
chat
becoming a community meme when someone
kills an enemy through
smoke has erratic mouse movement or
otherwise just makes an unlikely play
it's time to spam back in the chat
simple checks into secret with the scout
to start things off
so good pick for navi now sports already
achieved 50
oh my god i'll get back to that in a
minute
goodbye oscar thank you for playing
today vac's popularity as a meme
is even recognized by the dota 2
community especially when someone pulls
off
an unbelievable skill shot yep
very well played oh the power shot
from off screen oh man
i know people complain about vag but my
goodness the aimbot is real
and as the vac system continues to
evolve
it also continues to make headlines with
the system reportedly banning over half
a million cs go players
the month that valve made the game free
to play so there you have it
vac as with anything valve touches it
seems to turn into a meme of some kind
eventually personally you're against
cheaters being automatically banned
no i'm against injecting diseases into
me for immunity
you mean anti-vaxxer facts just don't
work
way to go man look what you've done
how can you play cs professionally and
host the show at the same time
what the [__] everyone says
you think i'm get right i don't the
people do well i saw somebody in the
comments said that i [__] look like
like like g-man from half-life 2.
so i don't think i don't take that [__]
too personally
pg shout out to the guy who noticed my
shirt
last episode that guy was cool he just
was like dude i'm buttering and i was
like hell yeah dude
[Laughter]
buttering